life after Liberation is far from Easy
especially when you're hungry there's no
food or power or running water
after months of Russian occupation and
hardship the share struggle to survive
breaks fragile bonds of unity which were
forged in the midst of War
s argue with pensioners over
Plies more urgently they've somehow come
through the bombing now they have to
find a way to live through what follows
foreign
has meant the forest is finally giving
up its secrets
among the detritus of War there is
constant evidence of the battle's
ferocity on land vehicles and people
but with every dead Russian soldier
discovered in the Wake Left Behind the
advancing Ukrainian Army there are
shocking discoveries too of the high
number of civilians who've perished
we saw War crime prosecutors setting off
to investigate possibly two Mass graves
in Lehman they want to know how they
died and whether atrocities have been
committed
the Russian corpses are left because
they can be booby-trapped even in death
they're a risk to the living
mineclear has told us their small group
alone is finding about a hundred Minds a
day and they're constantly spotting
illegal cluster bombs disguised as
leaves
convince you foreign
even a rough calculation of deaths is
near impossible with so many hastily
buried in back Gardens and civilians are
still very much in the path of the
continuing bombardment
vassal's Got No Way Out
there's a constant barrage of of shells
coming in and the locals are saying it
was a very Fierce number coming in over
the past 12 hours or so
[Applause]
foreign
this route of the Russians on the
Eastern front and the continuing
pressure down south 2 is expected to
provoke yet more brutal retaliation
whilst the ukrainians are still coping
with how quickly they pulled out and the
challenges that's brought so looking at
what's been left behind there's a lot of
discarded ammunition
they seem to have taken off their
uniforms and that's what we're finding
from many of the ukrainians who are
taking them prisoners that they're
trying to blend in with the local
population and poses civilians now
there were medals for those who'd fought
to retake Lehman
[Applause]
and the constant War Rumble means
there's no time to rest
but with every success they get Bolder
and more determined
Alex Crawford Sky News on the Eastern
front in Ukraine